buenos días esta cumbre de dos días ha
arrancado con una advertencia del
gobierno británico a rusia si invade
ucrania entonces se enfrentará a
gravísimas consecuencias económicas la
ministra de exteriores británica liz
atrás se reunió ya esta mañana con el
secretario de estado de los eeuu anthony
blinken ambos coincidieron en su apoyo a
ucrania la profunda preocupación por la
concentración de tropas rusas en esa
frontera con ucrania y dijeron que
cualquier incursión sería un error
estratégico y es que lo que se busca es
que el g7 tenga unidad frente a rusia
sobre ucrania tras llame o también a que
europa acabe con la dependencia del del
gas y de la energía por parte de rusia
es importante también esta cumbre porque
se hablará sobre la situación actual en
afganistán en y además en irán y también
es el debut de la nueva ministra de
exteriores alemana anabella barbour
porque este país alemania tendrá la
presidencia del g7 en el 2022 y el
domingo del g7 abordará las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 y también la
seguridad sanitaria mundial que podemos
esperar
podemos esperar que se haga una revisión
de la situación actual de la pandemia
del cob y 19 en todo el mundo cómo
enfrentar esa gran amenaza que se ve que
es omicron para todo el mundo pero sobre
todo revisar las metas sobre cómo ayudar
a que los países en desarrollo puedan
tener acceso a las vacunas rápidamente
entonces por ello se revisará justamente
cuál puede ser esa alternativa para
lograr el acceso a estas vacunas
recordemos que en junio de este año los
líderes del g-7 se comprometieron a
entregar mil millones de dosis de
vacunas una meta altamente criticada
primero porque son muy pocas para la
cantidad de vacunas que se necesitan
para toda la población mundial y además
porque llegarían muy tarde los
científicos de diferentes países han
advertido que por ejemplo la falta de
vacunas en áfrica permitieron la
aparición de la variante omicron esta
cumbre de ministros de exteriores y
desarrollo aquí en inglaterra se da en
medio de advertencias de los científicos
de este país que han advertido que si no
se toman las medidas
si no se hacen cambios y los contagios
de omicron continúan como hasta el
momento a finales de diciembre el reino
unido- alcanzará el millón de de
infecciones de la variante omicron y se
ha dicho por supuesto que esta cumbre de
dos días en liverpool es cobit se cure
es segura contra el kobe pero habrá que
esperar cuáles son las medidas
alternativas que se anuncian